you get my outfit
did get it no why am i what comment
knives out I should have brought my
brick okay family gathered to celebrate
your father's 85th birthday how was it
good party pre my dad's death it's great
[Music]
what can we ask why has something
changed
no it hasn't changed or no we can't ask
what you're suggesting
[Music]
of your ass
what an interesting remix of the son
something spill it
I suspect
eliminated no suspects
[Music]
we're not finished
[Music]
who done it who done it man
really does feel like a really nice
whodunit tale that's exactly what
apparently he wanted to do was take it
back old-school style
get everybody trapped in a house like
clue or something like that
there was another trailer we watched
recently though uh yeah yeah the one
with the dinner party and the fan yeah
the bride or whatever this murder
mysteries are making a comeback of sorts
it also has a little bit of a bad times
at the El Royale vibe to it
I like these kind of tales anyway just
like contain stories figuring out the
whole mystery and have a lot of plot
twists and maneuvers it's a trailer so
maybe not but based off like the moments
were it slowed down had some breath even
with Chris Evans is kind of dialogue
this might be his funniest movie he's
ever done it looks a little more zany
than I expected it to be yeah that's one
of the biggest takeaways from this
trailer was just that Chris Evans looks
like he's having a blast doing something
totally different
yeah from Captain America and and I mean
you know I'm excited to see Rian Johnson
working with an ensemble like this one
again I mean Star Wars is obviously
ensemble my big intro it was brick I
know I might be wearing a Star Wars
shirt but but I want to ignite a rage
not last Jedi in any fashion good or bad
that's a brick back in the that's a
great man great a great movies great
we're not gonna argue as much about cuz
it's much more agreeable there's no
established lore for brick to alt it
kind of reminded me of that in the sense
that I like seeing him go back to
something a bit more grounded and
something that's gonna play on his
strengths is just a clever writer of
characters and situations and stuff like
that yeah I mean he's really good at
drawing from whatever inspired him to
become a filmmaker even from his works
from brick and looper he's at or who
really works within genre exploring this
level of johna it sounds excited to me I
couldn't help but flash to the girl with
the dragon tattoo when I was looking at
Christopher Plummer here and I was like
oh yeah Daniel Craig Oh dad no
Christopher Plummer are both in The Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo it that our
aesthetic whatever the lens is
them and just looks like that it kind of
plucked out of there just a bit I was
slightly distracted by the voice Daniel
Craig was doing because he's dressed
like Bond is doing a different voice
yeah look he's Stanfill this okay this
is the kind of cast you just that I
think if you are a cinephile the cast
like this would get you excited and
knowing that you have a director like
Rian Johnson who really cares about
character the end of the day he really
does oh boy
I mean you can dislike the direction he
took Star Wars all day but I don't think
you can accuse his take on it of being
lazy or you know undercooked I mean even
if you didn't cook it in a direction
that everybody agrees with you know I I
don't think you can count that movie as
lazy you got this wide range of talent
of like male and female actors infused
in here Toni Collette who rightfully won
the Oscar for hereditary yeah you got
Toni Collette in here Jamie Lee Curtis
and of course all the dudes as well
Michael Shannon I'm always excited to
see him pop up in anything I guess - I'm
curious to know what the actual tone of
this movie is going to play like I
wonder if the trailer is trying to sell
us a little bit more on some of the zany
ness kookiness because of the fact that
this is a murder mystery coming out
around Thanksgiving time so they're
trying to like have this like
dysfunctional family fun vibe to it yeah
yeah which I did a marketing standpoint
that makes sense to me I'm just sort of
wondering well will it be as Bonnie yes
this trailer is sort of making it out to
be I'm sure we'll have the humor but I
have to imagine that there's some kind
of edge that might not fully be
represented here because each of Ryan
Johnson's films I can think of
they don't shy away from going there
when they need to and when they get me
to get uglier they need to get kind of
visceral or scary they go there so so I
feel like there's a possibility for that
here and you know I also yeah I wonder
how that tone is gonna play out with
just one central murder or if there's
gonna be more mayhem that ensues beyond
this point because the main gist of this
trailer is just like everybody's
gathered together and we don't know who
killed him
yeah you know but I feel like there's
still a ton more stuff to be revealed
about this and the main thing that gets
me excited is just the promise of the
ensemble and the whole like Ryan Jones
is really good that kind of stuff too so
to see what all these characters are
gonna be like you know it's like it is
kind of distracting the Daniel Craig has
that sort of southern dandy accent but
at the same time I'm really excited to
see him get into a totally different
character like that you know especially
with like the Agatha Christie stuff
we've seen lately a Murder on the Orient
Express coming back and stuff I wonder
if maybe this can grab people in a way
that maybe that didn't it has some of
that tradition in there but this
definitely seems like it's got its
modern sensibility and it's got its own
thing going on so well out of all of his
pieces this feels like the most omage in
terms of him like developing an original
piece this original piece also feels the
most like in tribute to so many
different yeah material from the past as
much as like a giant cast list like this
tends to get me excited I also can get
slightly concerned because of the Cal
like this is a very very slight concern
sometimes when situations like this cast
members try to outshine each other as
opposed to just you know everyone being
on the same playing field and really
working together I don't imagine it's
gonna be like that all around and I got
nothing everyone here was just with a
giant freaking you go on set and ruin
just wants to be the number one player
other than that one moment with Chris
Evans saying like each hit they're all
those people who that was the only time
I really got a sense for the chemistry
as a group and not just the
personalities individually I guess for a
second trailer I don't want to see a
little bit more of what their dynamics
are when the family is all interacting
with each other and the third act you
know the reveals and stuff like Jen I
don't want there to be much mystery go
sure this movie sure yeah sure I like
the knives the knives thrown the time to
iron knives through the back of the
background they're circular yeah like
what kind of family is this that's one
of those things where I'm like if you're
detective and you walk into a house
where murders happened and they have a
big old knife wheel I'm like you know
that yeah like you're not leaving here
until you
got a few people I think or until you're
dead yourself well guys you excited for
Ryan Johnson's new film knives out leave
a comment in the comment boxes where
comments belong you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and hey if you made it this far
watch go ahead extend your reject trip
all the patreon page I am so smooth at
talking about this over there we do
weekly Q&A s as well as TV show reaction
stream alongs
for shows like Cobra Kai season to
Gotham Jon develop haunting a hill house
and then there are other shows where we
have stream belongs and reaction
highlights with footage included from
the show those are attack on Titan my
hero academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood one punch man and
supernatural please go on over to our
patreon page and check it out as soon as
you can it's a good time plenty of
alcohol required gets stuck man eyes
see you guys
you